معارك طحينه تدور موضوع اكثر من سته اشهر
بين الجيش الروسي الذي يحاول السيطره على
مدينه باخمت والقوات الاوكرانيه اليوم
باتت قريه فوليدار الواقعه جنوب باخمض
نقطه ساخنه للقتال القوه الروسيه تقول
انها تواصل تنفيذ عمليه هجوميه ناجحه
بالقرب منها الامر الذي تم فيه هيك
من مجموعه القوات الشرقيه عمليه
تقع فوليدار بالقرب من المكان الذي يحمي
فيه خط المواجهه الشرقيه خطوط السكك
الحديديه التي تسيطر عليها روسيا والتي
تزود قوات موسكو في جنوب اوكرانيا بالمؤن
والعتاد رئيس مجموعه بدر العسكري الخاصه
الموعوده ليتسنى لاوكرانيا العوده الى وضع
الهجوم وفي الاسابيع الماضيه تعاهدت الدول
الغربيه بارسال المئه من الدبابات الحديثه
والمركبات المدرعه لتجهيز القوات
الاوكرانيه لهجوم مضاد لكن ارسال هذه
الاسلحه سيكون بعد اشهر ما يترك كيف
لتقاتل خلال الشتاء فيما توصف بانها حرب
استنزاف